there are new urgent warnings this
morning about the country's climbing
coronavirus numbers which
show infections rising in 47 states
there are now over 9 million coronavirus
cases in the united states rising by
nearly a hundred thousand new cases
friday alone in the last two weeks a
million more people
tested positive and in 16 states the
number of cases is at an all-time high
all of this as the number of lives lost
approaches 230
thousand with cold weather moving in and
more events shifting inside
health experts fear the worst of the
pandemic is yet to come
here to help us make sense of it all is
michael george who has been covering the
pandemic
michael good morning michelle good
morning a second wave is
indeed here that's how oregon's governor
put it friday
some states are doubling down others
though are still resisting stricter
safety measures
in the immediate future there's an
election and halloween today only
complicating ways to combat the
country's
mounting tragedy
a new trick to get a treat in a pandemic
may be just a drop in the bucket
even a socially distanced candy pipe
shoot still allows costumed kids to face
risks if they go out tonight the plastic
masks that go with the costumes
they're not the same as the cloth masks
we're talking about so advise moms and
dads to
make a cloth mess that goes with the
costumes and for voters in line to be
tuesday's election day rush
extraordinary safety protocols weren't
enough
to stop one florida polling place from
shutting down
after covid hit overstretched hospitals
are telling a much
more tragic story icu beds are 80
percent full
in nearly a quarter of u.s hospitals
according to a federal government memo
obtained by national public radio a
mounting tragedy
that could have been avoided a third of
the population
that believes this pandemic is a hoax
and they believe that it will end
next wednesday and no public health
messaging is having an
impact on that population certainly
not in wisconsin where the democratic
governor tony evers
can't get the republican legislature to
support safety measures
if we want to do this right and stop it
in its tracks
people have to wear a freaking mask
south dakota is battling a positivity
rate of 46 percent
california wants to avoid that and has
halted some plans to loosen restrictions
you're seeing 20 30 plus percent
positivity rates now in other parts
of our country we're at 3.0 percent
over 14 day period 3.2 over 7 day
but we are not taking our eye on the
ball we've got to box
this disease end oregon 2 is considering
clamping down
after the state saw record case numbers
this week
oregon's cases are rising just like the
rest of the countries are
and frankly cases around the globe
the second wave that we've all been
worried about
is here and for the second time testing
of an experimental covet 19
antibody drug has been paused to
investigate a safety issue
that could impact severely ill patients
regeneron pharmaceuticals said they will
continue to test
less sick patients jeff all right
michael thank you very much